alors déjà la première question qu'on va
vous poser est ce que le spectacle des
[ __ ] est un spectacle incontournable
et ensuite on va revenir et on a plein
d'infos sur les artistes qui balance sur
les [ __ ] alors est ce que c'est un
show incontournable on a le top 10 des
meilleurs shows pas là on va voir
quelques extraits vous pour vous
benjamin castaldi moi aujourd'hui c'est
incontournable mort si elle est
effectivement le programme qui marche le
mieux sur sur tf1 donc quelles que
soient les petites polémiques on peut
entendre de ci de là il faut que je
continue parce que et malheureusement il
dirait qu'ils ont besoin des restos
alors on va revenir sur les polémiques
dans un instant puisque vous allez voir
les déclarations de certains lycéens
quand honda pour répondre à votre
question
alors justement il ya un duo incroyable
qu'on voulait vous montrer c'est entre
jean-jacques goldman et céline dion 684
d'en regarder
[Musique]
je sais
capa
[Musique]
je
papa
allah
dans 94 alors spectacle incontournable
gilbert hélas non ça ne l'est plus mais
depuis le départ de jean jacques goldman
l'esprit est cassée s'est fissurée il ya
plus le patriarche a plus le patron ça a
changé voilà je trouve que le spectacle
a perdu en intensité
isabelle spectacle pur il rapporte quand
même il a rappelé en 2010 16 et 2017
casbah la question des années par
ailleurs vachiery oui dans les airs pour
ça que je le soutiens à la sasp et
convient de rappeler mais sans moubarak
alors là on a vraiment du show en
lui-même mathieu et ben non je rejoins
gilles franchement sur parle du show lui
même il est devenu très très décevant
les grandes marques mais pardon des
grandes stars qui venait avant que sonne
maurane céline dur et où elles sont
c'est dur même elle vient peut y être
attachées tout est fait j'attends qu'on
me voit chanter michaël youn jeunes
adorent mais c'est passé sécurité que
c'est sur un plateau incroyable c'était
un véritable show comment il a pu en
france ce n'est plus avérée alors moi
c'est une émission de variétés je suis
pas d'accord avec vous parce qu'il ya
des artistes et à big flo idées qui sont
rentrés ont valu 12 et à céline dion
veulent essayer ces dépenses les plus
grosses stars du moment excusez moi je
suis et vous d'être ringard excédé vous
notre arrière sous d'idées et là encore
il est aujourd'hui voilà c'est sinon
valérie claessen toute la scène
française moderne et là il ya des gens
qui mentent tu vas de soprano à matt
pokora en passion morbide flo et oli
ils sont tous là c'est ça l'intelligence
c'est qu'on a conservé des gens comme
kad merad et caetera et on a ouvert au
pana un panel beaucoup plus jeune donc
le plateau et il parle aux 7 77 ans
c'est là où un sérieux tournant alors
jean-mi vous vous avez choisi par
exemple un extrait vous avez choisi le
duo entre johnny et véronique sanson il
y avait trop excité ou et vous à nous
donner votre avis vous êtes plutôt de
l'avis de mathieu de l'anglais regardez
[Musique]
non
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
alors dans les selles ça reste
évidemment un très beau spectacle c'est
très bien mais chez ces traits produit
c'est très bien produit voilà c'est une
très belle scène voilà mais avant je
gagnais beaucoup de talent musical et
beaucoup de duos qui était vraiment
percutant ou halak était bon et
maintenant c'est beaucoup une succession
de saynètes en place tous les people qui
viennent pour faire des sketchs un peu
comme ça et beaucoup moins une émission
musicale et vidéo incroyable alors que
mathieu vous dites que vous n'avez même
pas aimé le spectacle mine de rien vous
m'avez dit que vous vous lire voir
absolument l'hommage de l'année dernière
qu'ils ont fait à johnny hallyday
ça c'est vrai c'est un hommage à johnny
je dis juste suivi et juste tourné en 3
secondes j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
des flowlines ça mais vous aussi pardon
vous dites parfois des bêtises je vais
pas me comparer duflot league qui débute
et céline dion et sa maman ont peut
coupler les deux il ya des très grandes
séries spéciales hier et il ya plein de
très gros char du moment où il ya des
très grandes stars ont la forme et
astier alors regardez johnny d'or
même à voir
je pense
[Applaudissements]
mangeas du dieu
[Musique]
alors les emplois spectacle a vraiment
je pense que c'est un bon programme et
au delà des stars c'est vrai il ya
céline dion c'est bien pourquoi pas
c'est pas que ces unions tu sais les
costumes surtout celle qui tourne à la
dérision y prennent des sketches ils
prennent des chansons d'un autre mec
c'est ça qu'on aime bien voir les voir à
faire la fête en costumes d'aiguiser
leur des risées ce que ça implique tacle
incontournable pour vous savez comme moi
c'est incontournable
c'est un canton du jura d'image sauf que
c'est un magnifique spectacle populaire
il ya des larmes
il ya du rire il ya des sourires il ya
tout et je trouve qu'il ya absolument tu
vois quand on a vu là il ya jean louis
aubert marc lavoine bruel la wii
benjamin castaldi non mais c'est comme
ça chaque année tu dis des grosses
bêtises je dis que c'est moi où j'ai
envie comme ça qu avant il n'y a pas
moins 9e pas moins de moyens maintenant
que y accéder pour le court terme
souvent dessus des fins alors ça leur
coûte de l'argent parce qu'ils y mettent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de pognon
pour produire ce spectacle est prévu ni
sagesse et honnêtement pour le coup
c'est un programme incontournable il
faut que ça continue il n'y a pas de
moins de vedettes gabon alors maxime
médard qui veulent pas venir après
maxime guinea justement vous vous avez
choisi un extrait c'est le sketch de
l'eurovision dans 2016 avec jean jacques
goldman qui jouent et excellemment
ouvrir le bal cette année on l'a su
le pays des saunas le pays des
krisprolls et des contes et comtesses
groupe de chasse en l'occurrence je suis
désolé mini four était alors vous c'est
un spectacle le canot c'est un véritable
tour de force encore aujourd'hui de
réunir des millions de téléspectateurs
véritable tour de force de réunir trente
trois artistes très différents est sur
vous et surtout de remplir sept concerts
à guichets fermés cette année ils vont
faire si ça sera tourné court en janvier
à bordeaux j'ai tous ceux qui disent que
c'est incontournable sont vénéneux et
dangereux pour le programme passe qui se
voilent la face
vous fermez les yeux mais y'a plein de
problèmes en ce moment si vous dites
c'est merveilleux ça quand on à l'europe
à régler
justement va parler des problèmes c'est
une très bonne condition
muriel robin propres historique des
[ __ ] qui n'y est plus depuis dix ans
a expliqué qu'elle ne voulait plus du
tout en entendre parler dix ans elle
expliqué pourquoi au micro d'rtl regarde
il parle des enfants aiment c'est la
question qu'on a tous envie de vous
poser non pour des cons dans l'autre
jamais voilà j'ai bien vu comme les
[ __ ]
j'étais pas indispensable ça marche sans
moi je n'y vais pas en 2008 parce que je
peux pas ça roule
l'audience est là bon alors ça roule
sans moi moi mais tombe je mets mon
énergie et mon temps et ma notoriété
ailleurs dans des plus petites
structures
voilà muriel robin donc voilà qui ne
sera pas voilà d'horizon forêt mais elle
a été plutôt diplomate un combat thomas
dutronc lui le fils bien sûr de jacques
dutronc a défoncé certaines
personnalités des [ __ ] c'est dans
l'interview son fils qu'il a lancé un
pavé dans la mare ou regarde on en parle
après il ya un côté bonne action
il ya un côté stressant quand même ce
qu'on se retrouve à chanter des trucs
des fois déguisé dans des machins boxer
il y a des fois un peu faut jouer du
coude aussi avec certains collègues qui
sont pas naturels dans leur manière
d'être et à qui ils sont là quand même
pour être vu pour se montrer à la télé
tout vivant de plus
mettre un coup de coude il ya des gens
comme ça là bas c'est laurent argelier
n'embrasse lolo alors les chiffres il
est l'animateur lance vous est ce que
vous pensez voilà la question qu'on vous
pose quand les artistes balance
est ce que ça vous plaît qui ballon sur
les [ __ ] pourquoi le film dans la
moindre petite association de village
dès qu'il ya plusieurs personnes il ya
des gars guerre dans un couple à partir
du moment où il ya deux personnes il ya
des galères en fait on aime tous ces
gens qui sont sur la scène
on n'a pas envie de savoir qu'ils ne
s'aiment pas quoi qu'il en soit cette
bande de personnes fait une bonne action
pour l'action publique et en même temps
ça fait un joli clin d'oeil à coluche et
c'est tout ce qu'on veut on n'a pas
besoin de savoir ça alors y allait de
ses gars aussi membre historique des
[ __ ] qui a quand même fait partie de
la troupe pendant 17 tours est et elle
aussi elle a également été très déçu de
l'attitude de certains membres de la
troupe elle en a parlé en début du mois
sur rtl regardez après vous avez donné
votre aimé passionnément cette aventure
j'ai aimé rire avec plein de copains
copines à moi j'y allais pas pour les
bogies à l'est pas pour faire ma promo
c'était intense et puis un jour je me
suis dit que je ne savais pas si je
retrouve encore l'esprit de coluche
voilà tout simplement en plus il faut
dire la vérité jean jacques est parti
quoi donc je crois que jean jacques
était tellement quelqu'un de discret et
de humble que c'est lui qui arrivait à
canaliser les ego donc tu te dis qu'en
est il des esgaulx une fois que cet
homme n'est plus là quoi alors les
artistes balance qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent et disent que c'est complètement
hors sujet - est-ce que les égos des
artistes mais rien à faire
voila voila c'est compliqué ouais ouais
ça oui je vous écoute mais c'est hors
sujet je trouve que c'est indécent c'est
malsain
il faut juste dire un cd c 17 repas
offert les états d'âme
jusqu'où les états d'âme des uns et des
autres elle a raison mais peu importe et
puis kanaky forcément qui jouent des
coudes ben c'est comme à la table
mathieu joue des coudes on le sait mais
on aime bien quand même pas que des
coups de tête parce qu'on voit son coût
d'évacuer qu'elle plus d'ego celui qui
est là bas qui effectivement veux
chanter le premier va voir koudrine
depuis une minute plus en avant ou
hélène pardon que j'aime beaucoup qui
justement dit comme et des crises d'égo
moi je vais pas le canal + le dégoût
dans tout ça au final on sait très bien
que meilleurs suis pas très généreux
déficit croissant et ses ultimes pendant
chansons derrière parce qu'un titre qui
passe aussi devant 9 millions de
personnes derrière leur télécharge on
sait tout ça mais au final le rapport à
leur talent peu importe
derrière il ya des gens qui mangent
grâce à ça c'est pourquoi l'un de ces
gars est tous ces zones là je pense que
dresse au terme de ne pas y aller c'est
pas grave mais ne critique pas je suis
les je vois pas pourquoi les [ __ ]
serait exemple des critiques qu'on peut
faire moi je connais des gens qui
aimeraient beaucoup et trop [ __ ] qui
n'y sont pas parce que les [ __ ]
quand même quelque part ya une coterie
il ya ceux qui ont la carte il ya ceux
qui ne l'ont pas et qu'ils ont avoué
qu'ils aimeraient bien que moi je ne
discute pas ce qu'ils incluent la bande
à fifi c'était très bien reçus match
exclu ceux qui sont dehors qui aimerait
bien en être et que les [ __ ]
n'accepte pas donc je suis désolé je ne
comprends pas on met des gens comme des
gens comme comme comme adamo par exemple
qui est passé une fois d'amour l'équipe
ne revient plus non mais même parmi les
jeunes
c'est pour ça que des gens comme stromae
c'est pour ça que déjà une eva par an
c'est pour ça qu'il dit mitchell qui lui
moi je veux pas me retrouver avec des
footballeurs
nul n'y vont plus est pourquoi leur
discours ne serait pas recevra va aussi
se joue pas pour les voleurs menée par
gilles muller ou du mit telle mise en
droit de le dire voilà mais alors vous
par exemple vous vous aimez voile par
l'idée nouveau vous avez adoré par les
masses surtout pendant le show se doit
de suivre son temps il ya des anciens
des nouveaux et des nouveaux comme des
fanas club que j'adore voilà la semaine
l'année dernière avec john hancock par
exemple qui a intégré la troupe ils ont
tendance aussi à prendre des gens à la
mode de la normale parce qu'il faudra le
dossier regardez c'est des gens mais je
veux juste que ça se passe bien parce
que c'est la première fois
c'est notre première fois j'ai pas envie
d'être en retard quand on pas qu'on
t'apprend bien fondé des mines en avant
si tu vois ce que je veux dire
ok ça commence bien oh ça marche comment
ça va salah patrick hubert on est juste
un peu tôt mais parce que papa c'est
assez grand là je je peux je peux vous
aider à acheter c'est vraiment super
grand tort de trop en dire autant de la
carrière de tout le monde ici un bien
problème vous n'êtes pas content vous
avez l'air si on est super content là on
est aux [ __ ]
alors que marcus taux plus bas lance
gilbert est ce que vous comprenez moi je
les comprends et pour qu'ils commencent
à balancer sur les [ __ ] qui est une
cause magnifique pour qu'il commence à
dire ça ça veut dire qu'en interne y
aller vraie cassure
il ya un vrai malaise qu'il faut régler
est ce que tu proposes alors il faut
qu'il faut que la parole sorte il faut
le régler
et moi je trouve qu'il faut un nouveau
leadership pour les [ __ ] je trouve
qu isabelle skate à ce cas d'israël je
trouve que ça c'est recevable aussi un
quand elle y voilà qui a des gens qui
sont extraits des arts visuels dernier
par exemple ces dernières années le
dernier alors il ya également pierre
palmade qui expliquait aussi qu'ils
voulaient plus y aller parce que c'est
plus du tout la même ambiance dans les
coulisses regard des partis-pris de
nouveaux pas aux [ __ ] c'est pas la
même ambiance dans les coulisses ça a
changé depuis le départ de nos bas
depuis le départ de jean jacques depuis
que beaucoup de jeunes chanteurs sont
arrivés ils ont pris les choses en main
donc je reconnais pas mes copains c'est
le sentiment de montres votre place dans
cette nouvelle troupe
je m'amuse mois dans les loges ouais
voilà ça s'est amusé moi sur scène donc
donc voilà alors venez pas la danse
marie de ré loges mais je trouve que
kelly de moins en moins de conneries je
suis assez fier mais vous elle a raison
il ya des gens qui arrivent et des gens
qui partent
voilà et c'est laisser la vie les
offrait peu parc lire toute la scène
française vous venez au lieu de tourner
le micro à ceux qui partent en premier
de temps à ceux qui à rire il ça serait
- ce serait plus logique alors assez
choqué la wii c'est ce qu'il fallait je
suis choquée parce que franchement qui
aide les gonades dans la suède les
gosses et sur le one man qui est en
train de dire finalement les petits
jeunes qui vont le plus complet le
succès de cette version et du cou
c'est pas bien ce qui fait bien palmade
alors la jalousie
on va passer aux travaux derrière en
troisième volet le sujet les artistes
peuvent-ils refuser les [ __ ] et là
je vous pose la question est ce que les
artistes peuvent refuser des [ __ ]
puisque à beaucoup d'artistes quand tout
simplement dit du mal de avec ont du mal
avec le concept en lui-même ce qu'a dit
eddy mitchell comme vous l'avez dit
voilà eddy mitchell qui a dit j'ai dit
que c'était une opération commerciale
c'est vrai tant mieux ça rapporte aux
restos du coeur
c'est le spectacle que je n'aime pas
mélanger des chanteurs des footballeurs
ou je ne sais quoi avec des déguisements
de patronage genre monsieur le curé
présence en moi c'est de l'humour
pitoyable rhône aussi partagent à peu
près le même avis que eddy mitchell ya
vianney aussi on va voir cette vidéo
dans un instant est-ce qu'on peut
refuser les [ __ ]
oui ou non francis qu'on vous l'a déjà
proposé moi ce que je pense c'est c'est
que non ne l'a jamais proposé ce que je
pense c'est que le succès des [ __ ]
ce qui fait le succès des [ __ ] c'est
la fidélité que le public français a
pour le rêve de coluche et donc peu
importe qui est sur la scène en fait le
public viendra parce que le public est
fidèle à ce rêve de coluche et le public
veut perpétuer cette volonté que quand
us ceux qui ont créé cette manifestation
de faire en sorte que des gens puissent
manger grâce à sa chanson bien sûr mais
français est-ce qu'on peut refuser ces
actions gmac c est ce qu on se refusait
d en bas je pense comme un artiste on
peut refuser mais il faut pas le dire à
la radio qui en privaient maintenant tu
peux très bien en tant qu'artisans moi
c'est pas mon truc et le biais de garder
pour toi et pas faire te faire de la
paix au moyen du lot il ya des artistes
aussi koala qui veulent passer un
passing qui veulent pas faire aussi des
sketches rien voilà les doit aussi
beaucoup aimé un sketch dans fort est
celui avec les princesses disney jeter
que delphine auffret
elle a adoré et c'est vrai que moi
j'avais envie par sonam en voie d'être à
leur place mais y'a deux mecs qui disent
moi c'est pas mon truc
regardez
voix en locaux après gilles icher des
princesses qui était contrainte de vivre
en coloc dans le même château
et oui c'était aussi la crise du
logement frais les princesses comme en
ces temps anciens tindle existait points
une fois l'an le prince charmant venez
choisir celles qu'ils allaient pécho
voilà c'était bien sûr vous l'avez
compris c'était bien sûr une parodie de
la belle au bois dormant
[Rires]
non mais moi je pense qu'on peut tout à
fait refuser l'invitation des [ __ ]
en revanche quand on décide quand on
explique pour quelles raisons c'est pas
la peine de dénigrer g qui est comme un
programme hyper important où il faut que
les gens non seulement à le voir mais
ensuite achète le disque donc on peut
dire moi ça ne me convient pas mais de
là à dire ce que font les autres lancers
de la merde c'est ça vient c'est une
ambiance comme ci comme ça
non on dit moi ça ne me contente comme
ce qu'a fait via n'est pas rien et
regarde et lui l'a dit regardez ce qu'il
a dit il reproche rien voilà pas proposé
je n'ai pas dit non j'ai dit que si on
proposait c'est vrai que je me voyais
mal
voilà j'ai dit ça sans prétention mais
ça fait des années moi que je m'investis
que je passe du temps étaient sans abri
que je dors avec eux tous les hivers
chaque semaine donc voilà pour moi c'est
une très belle mission il n'y a pas de
débat là dessus
en revanche sur la qualité artistique je
pense avoir le droit de dire sans
méchanceté que je me retrouve pas dans
ce qu'ils ont fait il exhorté quel
exemple pour moi on ne peut pas refuser
je critique le programme mais on y va
c'est une cause sacrée
oui parfois c'est mauvais oui la
démarche artistique mais on y va la
cause il ya des gens qui ont besoin des
repas des [ __ ] pour manger pour sa
gueule et on y vend sur cette voie là
gaza 2 6 qui a visiblement pas trop
envie d'y aller regarder feriez les
[ __ ]
non je ferai pas pourquoi parce que j'ai
pas envie de chanter avec mimie mathy et
de faire les sketches et d'après la
cause c'est comme le truc de coluche et
c'est quelque chose que je respecte mais
après je sais j'ai pas envie d'aller
faire des sketchs à la télé je préfère
faire mes choses moi-même mais
une façon un peu de se dévaloriser non
non c'est pas ça s'est passé m
c'est pas mon truc c'est tout c'est pas
trop une question ça c'est plus sur la
forme en fait alors si vous faisiez vous
un peut-on refuser les [ __ ]
m'envoyer des intrus non je trouve que
c'est pas bien ce qu'ils font ça se fait
pas c'est pas mon truc j'ai pas envie
ici la pembina les gens ils n'ont pas
envie d'aller au boulot le matin et y
vont c'est moi parlez nous quand on va
au concert et qu'on paye leur place 80
balle on y va on paye la place ont
laissé nos artistes on a envie de les
voir sur scène on n'a pas envie ça veut
dire quoi j'ai pas envie c'est par
contre moi j'ai pas envie de te voir aux
victoires de la musique là tu trouves du
temps pour le buteur la musique du temps
quand ils ont des promos affaire il
trouve dans les [ __ ] ses bouquets
six mois une l'a10 en janvier tu trouves
une journée et détourner de tout ça et
dans mais si la guerre pas aujourd'hui
que les pompiers arrivent à faire s'il y
en a plein qui font d'autres choses pour
des associations maintenant le voilà qui
veut qui a dit nous qui vous non plus
qu'ils voulaient pas nier le maître gims
fait plein de choses pour les
associations on est heureusement la
regarder ce qu est ce qu ils capturent
je serai pas à l'aise dans ce monde là
avec ces artistes là que je respecte
beaucoup mais je me sentirai hypocrite
je ferais sont blancs j'ai fait semblant
d'être là bas avec eux à me déguiser à
mettre des colons déguisant en peter pan
ou ou en bonbons ou on ne sait pas quand
est ce que veut dire j'y arriverai pas
faire ça arriverait pas sa longueur des
matchs sur l'hypocrisie des jo et la
tendresse et la prison contre le
principe de gens qui n'ont pas mangé ça
mérite de faire remonter sur scène voilà
ce que non mais voilà par exemple maître
gims que je dis oui il fait plein de
choses pour tous l'association des
céréales à la qui se sont compacts du
spectacle c'est pas que les restos du
coeur un wydad sud en fait c'est super
incompatibles pas ce sont des artistes
dont qu'ils sont censés être extraverti
et aller vers les gens et le fait de pas
vouloir mettre de collants ça montre
juste qu'ils seront très timide et pas
vouloir se mélanger aux autres c'est
juste qu'ils sont un peu insatiable dans
leurs fans en est on peut passer d'un
point de vue artistique certaines
personnes peut-être comme francis à des
grands chanteurs et tout n'est pas
forcément une chaîne tv kirby m e gérard
jugnot des gens qui chantent faux on
peut l'entendre aussi va pour une cause
mais
exceptionnellement j'ai envie de revoir
ce moment-là 192 ch et que c'est votre
moment préférant ministre et maxime le
forestier et vanessa paradis rien si les
boucliers vous faire
et entendent autour
qui sait surtout guérir
merci
quand
lumineux
fabuleux
on dit dieu sur marchand cancer
g
enfin
[Musique]
mr
[Applaudissements]
il ya également booba qui a dit je
trouve leur manière de faire hypocrite
vu de l'extérieur on dirait une chorale
quasi sectaire qui se fait la promo sur
le malheur des autres
patrick sébastien qui explique que même
coluche ne prendrait très mal de voir la
troupe actuelle des [ __ ] et il ya
même florent pagny qui n'est pas fan du
tout il avait expliqué dans tout le
monde en parle regarder en deuxième un
des rares à critiquer les intouchables
restos du coeur qui en france aux
critiques et les restos du coeur oui le
départ coluche avait voulu ça pour aider
les pauvres et maintenant ça se
substitue à l'état c'est pas ça qu'il
voulait lui au départ oui parce que lui
il avait fait ça pour prouver justement
à l'état qu'ils étaient incompétents
faim qu'ils n'allaient pas et qu'il
pouvait le faire et qui c'était un mec
comme lui qui était en train de le
réussir
donc voilà pour durer voilà excusez moi
je peux dire un truc
oui bien sûr il me semble que tout ça
est un faux débat parce qu'en fait je
pense que tant que ça se passe bien
entre les artistes et moi je sais que je
me rappelle une fois j'avais demandé à
participer c'est en 86e moment de la
chanson du passage et ils ont refusé que
je le fasse je me suis dit on n'a pas
besoin de moi
c'est ce qui compte c'est que ce c'est
que ce qu'on peut faire pour créer du
lien et pour donner à manger aux gens
soient fait maintenant aujourd'hui si ce
truc là devait s'arrêter par exemple est
ce que les gens ont vraiment avec ce qui
s'est passé avec ce que le message qu'a
transmis coluche est ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin de ce spectacle pour que chacun
ait donné 80 balle au resto du lait les
fruits alors que finalement aujourd'hui
les restos du coeur ça existait beaucoup
de bénévoles et il donne à manger à des
classes faurecia nouveau news que ça
fait ça d'une manière incroyable
ces programmes qui m'a alors qu'il
faisait à continue que c'est important
oui c'est un des gros artistes mais tu
le vends derrière c'est plus que les
gens doivent donner de l'argent même son
spectacle chanté le plus gros